he came back
crisis on infinite earth to play
superman i know that was a that was a
big deal for you
that was a big deal did you get
i don't know i mean was there ever a
time where you got a little emotional
putting that suit back on oh for sure
absolutely really i mean yeah
yeah i i uh
thank goodness also because
yeah
you know the first time was such a
so much pressure and that i was trying
not to look at and also couldn't even
conceive of and i was like oh i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna get to and i'm gonna
appreciate the next one or i'm gonna you
know
relax into the next one i just have to
kind of get through this and
enjoy it but
i wouldn't have the awareness that i
have now and there was just great a lot
of gratitude for for having the
opportunity to to do this again for all
the parties that made it possible
um
and you know the i i've told the story
before but the first day that i came on
the set
i was shooting the bat
batwoman episode
and um his first time was appearing as
superman
in it
and i just was i thought this i've
already done it
like i've already i don't even if i even
if this was the only scene i'm doing
the emotional wound or scar
that was left from my experiences
returns was what was was mostly healed
because all the lead-up to that the
costume fitting the fan the wonderful
warm
fan reaction people were excited and
appreciated having
me returned to the character um was
validating and healing in so many ways
that being there was that first day
um was was the most magical of times and
and
i was able to kind of relax and
appreciate the rest of the experience
from that moment exciting i didn't have
to prove anything and i had nothing
there was nothing more to prove just
being there the fact that i had done
that and read the journey
not had the character for so long and
still was thought of i guess highly
enough or enough to to reprise even for
that a little bit was
was a validation i didn't know that i
needed
uh i guess um it was very healing did
you did you think that
so there was no i thought of like how am
i going to play this guy because you
already played it right you already knew
what you were doing they didn't ask you
to well well in this world we want you
to play it a little differently or we
want you to be i mean was there any sort
of
or just hey you or this guy just play
this guy again
no there was definitely there was
definitely um
some some considerations to be made it
is the same character but he's gone
through a lot since
superman returns um having lost lois
lane um and a lot of other other friends
killed by the joker um as you were kind
of mixing
um
uh uh
kingdom come storyline with the superman
returns backstory
in this so it's a different older more
mature
uh
superman and clark kell
um
then you had to play the angry uh
possessed
superman uh which is not something i'd
ever done before so i had to
tap into that and ground that so there
was definitely some challenges to to be
had and
and
tweaks to the character but i've been
thinking for a long time you know as i
as i'd become a parent and matured and
started learn
more things about myself and
uh i was eager to bring that
wisdom to the character which
you know
i think is is their
not even when he's speaking but it's
kind of in the non-moving moments it's
kind of in the quiet moments where that
i think some of that stuff plays